اهلا بكم لقي 15 جنديا مصريا ومدنيان
اثنان حتفهم وجرح 24 في سلسله هجمات فجر
الخميس على حواجز عسكريه بشمال سيناء
وتاتي هذه الهجمات بالتزامن مع المصادقه
على اول احكام عسكريه بالاعدام وهي
الاحكام التي صدرت بحق سبعه من [__]
الانقلاب في مصر نتوقف مع هذا الخبر
لنناقش في
محورين كيف يمكن ان ينعكس دخول احكام
عسكريه بهذه القسوه ضد المعارضين على حاله
عدم الاستقرار الامني المستمره في
مصر وما مدى نجاعه مقاربه السلطات المصريه
للاوضاع في البلاد على ضوء التطورات
الامنيه والقضائيه الاخيره
في هجمات شنها الخميس مسلحون على خمسه
حواجز عسكريه بشمال سيناء قتل واصيب عشرات
الجنود المصريين وذلك بعد ساعات من
تصريحات عسكريه اكدت سيطره السلطات التامه
على الاوضاع في شبه جزيره سيناء وبينما
ابقت هجمات الخميس الاسئله مفتوحه بشان
نجاعه الحمله العسكريه المصريه في شبه
الجزيره المضطربه جاءت الاخبار من من
القاهره تؤكد المصادقه على اول احكام
اعدام عسكريه صدرت بحق رافضين
للانقلاب كان يمكن لهذه المحاكمه ان تكون
الاولى والاخيره عنها صدر اول حكم
بالاعدام على خلفيه تداعيات الانقضاض على
حكم الرئيس المنتخب محمد مرسي لكن القضاء
المصري ابى الا اي يتجاوز نفسه
فالمحكمة في نهايه المطاف اما المتهمون في
القضيه المعروفه بعرب شركس فكانت محاكمتهم
عسكريه ما يعني انعطافا يكاد يكون انقلابا
في مسار القضايا المنظوره امام المحاكم
المصريه وخاصه تلك التي صدرت فيها احكام
بالاعدام على تيار سياسي دون غيره وهؤلاء
يقدرون بنحو
1500 سياسي وناشط معارض صدرت احكام اعدام
بالجمله في حقهم حكم على المتهمين في قضيه
عرب شركس وعددهم سبعه بالاعدام وسرعان ما
صدقت تلك الاحكام فقد اتهم السبعه
باستهداف نقيله جنود وقتل عدد منهم لكن
منظمات حقوقيه تحدثت بالادله عن تجاوزات
اجرائيه جسيمه خلال محاكمتهم والاهم ان
بعض المتهمين كان معتقلا بالفعل لحظه وقوع
الحادث وثمت محاضر موثقه تثبت اعتقالهم
وشكاوى مؤكده من الاهالي عن وقائع اختفاء
ذويه من المتهمين قبل واثناء وبعد الهجوم
المتهمين بالقيام به اكثر من ذلك تؤكد
المنظمه العربيه لحقوق الانسان في
بريطانيا تعرض المتهمين الى تعذيب بالغ
القسوه لاجبارهم على الاعتراف بالتهم
المنسوبه اليهم فماذا كانت النتيجه
المصادقه على اعدامهم جماعيا لا اعاده
النظر في القضيه ذلك سبب كاف حسب ناشطين
ومراقبين ومنظمات حقوقيه
لتشجيع العنف كوسيله وحيده متاحه للتعبير
عن معارضه النظام في مصر ما دامت التهم
جاهزه لاشخاص يؤتى بهم من بيوتهم ويعتقلون
وتصدر الاحكام باعدامهم من دون ان يرتكبوا
اي فعل يحاكم المرء عليه امام محكمه مدنيه
فضلا عن ان تكون عسكريه في هذه الاجواء
تاتي هجمات سيناء وسواها خمس هجمات
متزامنه على حواجز عسكريه في شمال سيناء
تقتل وتصيب عشرات الجنود واللافت ان تاتي
هذه الهجمات غداه حديث السلطات بفائض ثقه
عن سيطرتها التامه على الامور في سيناء
يحدث ذلك في مصر التي يتبع اعلامها سلطتها
ويروج لها فما ان بدات الحرب على الحوثيين
في اليمن حتى بدا الاعلام نفسه يتحدث عن
ضبط ارهابيين حوثيين في سينا تلك مقتضيات
وادوات قضاء يشمخ واعلام يردح على ما يقول
معارضون موضوع حلقتنا نناقشه مع ضيفين في
الاستوديو استاذ العلوم السياسيه الدكتور
عصام عبد الشافي ومن واشنطن توفيق حميد
الباحث في الشؤون المصريه مرحبا بكما اهلا
وسهلا دكتور عبد الشافي في مسار معاكس
تماما للتط مينات العسكريه القائله بان
الاوضاع مسيطره عليها تماما في شبه جزيره
سيناء تاتي هذه الهجمات ما الذي يعني بسم
الله الرحمن الرحيم هو
التصريحات كثيره جدا تعددت خلال العام
ونصف منذ انقلاب 3 يوليو وحتى الان هناك
في ما من مناسبه تمر حتى وتخرج تصريحات من
المتحدث العسكري باسم القوات المسلحه
ويؤكد على نجاح الحل الامني او الحلول او
الهجمات العسكريه التي تقوم بها المؤسسه
العسكريه في شبه جزيره سيناء ولكن بين
الحين والاخر تتعدد الهجمات تتعدد عمليات
استهداف الجنود تتعدد عمليات استهداف
المنشات الامنيه وهو ما يؤكد عدم قدره هذه
القوات وهذه الحمله التي استمرت لنحو
عامين حتى الان على تحقيق حات تذكر بدليل
انه بدلا من امام الافراط في استخدام
القوه من جانب المؤسسه العسكريه في مواجهه
اهالينا في شبه جزيره سيناء ثم القيام
بعمليه تفريغ شبه كامل لما يقرب من 14 م م
مربع على حدود في حدود رفح المصريه كانت
النتيجه معاكسه ان هناك تنظيم هناك جماعه
اعلنت انتمائها لتنظيم الدوله الاسلاميه
ان هناك المزيد من الكراهيه في مواجهه من
جانب الاهالي وبالتالي لم تعد من وجهه نظر
الشخصيه ان الفشل الكبير او الاخفاق
الكبير في الحمله على شبه جزيره سيناء
التي شنها الاجهزه العسكريه والامنيه في
مصر مرتبطه بدرجه كبيره بغياب الحاضنه
الشعبيه لهذه العمليات بمعنى ان المزيد من
القمع والقهر والتشريد والتجريف والتهجير
كلها ادت الى غياب هذه الحضينه الشعبيه في
مواجهه العمليات العسكريه وبالتالي كل
كلما زادت عمليات القمع كلما كان ذلك
دافعا لمزيد من الفشل في هذه الحمله السيد
توفيق 20 شهرا او او تزيد والمواجهه
مستمره ومفتوحه ما الذي يجعل الحسم غير
ممكن الى حد الان
اولا في اسباب عديده ولو تلاحظ حضرتك ان
عمليه موضوع الارهاب ده ليس فقط مصر اللي
بتعاني منه لمده الطويله يعني حتى
الولايات المتحده بكل امكانياتها قعدت في
موضوع الارهاب ولم تزل فيه مده طويله ولكن
احنا نقول بالنسبه لحاله مصر ان بعد
ثورات ثورتين في مده قصيره في حاله من عدم
الاستقرار في حاله من التناحر والتنافر
المجتمعي ما بين فكرين في في المجتمع ا في
احيانا نقص عتاد مثلا يعني مثلا الاداره
الامريكيه لسه امبارح قررت تبعت الاسلحه
لمصر تاخير هذه الاسلحه برده كان من
العوامل اللي خلت الارهابيين يشعروا ان
مصر في موقف ضعف ويزيدوا
هجومهم بعد كده في عوامل اخرى زي مثلا عدم
وجود راضع قوي يعني ان ارى حضرتك بتتكلم
عن وجود احكام ا ا عسكريه احنا طبعا كمبدا
عام نتمنى ان يبقى في عدل لكل مواطن دي ما
فيهاش مناقشه ولكن انا بقول ان الارهابيين
هنا هم اللي دفعوا النظام ان هو يضطر
يستخدم احكام راضعه لان من غير عمليه راضع
قويه ممكن الارهابيين دول يزدادوا اكثر في
افعالهم وفي الاهم من كل ده ان الارهاب هو
عرض لمرض وليس هو المرض فالمرض هو ظاهره
التطرف الفكري وهذه لم اراها عولجت جدا
ديا بعد هي تحتاج لعلاج ايديولوجي او فكري
تحتاج لعمل يعني منظم لمكافحه التطرف في
الفكر وليس فقط الارهاب اللي هو يعتبر
المرض الناتج عن ولكن سيد توفيق يعني هذه
الجماعات لا تبدو معزوله لا تبدو معزوله
هناك حاضنه شعبيه هذه الحظن الشعبيه التي
على ما يبدو النظام لم يقدر على استماله
هذا
الوسط الاجتماعي لصالحه الا الا يعني ذلك
ان هناك ايضا فشل في هذا
المستوى لا انا اعتقد هو مش فشل لان احنا
لو هنرى على المستوى النوعي حصل نقص يعني
بعد ما كانت العمليات بنرى فيها عربيات
كبيره بتنفجر زي عمليات مديريه امن
المنصوره وغيرها وفي القاهره كان في
عمليات ضخمه جدا ولكن هناك تغيير ما اقدرش
اقول كمي لكن اقدر اقول نوعي في قدره
المتطرفين اقصى حاجه يعملوها النهارده
قنابل محدوده اسلحه محدوده يعني قدرتهم
على التنظيم على مستوى كبير عشان يعملوا
عمليه ضخمه كل ماده بتقل ولكن لما تضع في
اعتبار حضرتك ان 70% من قاده القاعده
والكثير من قاده حتى داعش حاليا هم من
المصريين للاسف اللي تطرفه عبر العقود
الاخيره فانا اعتقد النظام المصري بيواجه
تجمع عش السنين من المتطرفين وعندنا نسبه
عاليه جدا منهم والظاهره لها جذور قويه في
المجتمع بقى لها سنين فاعتقد ان مجابهتها
يعني يعني ليس من العدل ان انتظر منهم بين
عش عشيه وضحاها ان يحلوها فالامر قد يحتاج
بعض الوقت ولكن لا مجادله ان هناك تغير
نوعي
في قدرتهم على احداث تفجيرات كبيره للغايه
مثل ما حدث في مديريه امد المنصوره طيب د
دكتور عسم ما الذي
يمد هذه المجموعات بالقدره على الاستمرار
لا هو اسمح لي في البدايه قبل الحديث عن
ما تتمتع به هذه الجمعات من القدره على
الاستمرار اعتقد ان هناك ملاحظات لابد من
توضيحها الحديث على ان الفشل او استمرار
هذه الحملات المطوله مرتبط بمفهوم الارهاب
وانتشار الجماعات الارهابيه ووجود تنافر
مجتمعي ووجود كما ذكر الدكتور الدكتور
توفيق نقص في العتاد وعدم وجود راتع كل
هذه الامور مردود عليها اذا كان هناك نقص
في العتاد العسكري لدى الاجهزه الامنيه
والعسكريه لا اعتقد انه اذا كان لدها هذه
الاجهزه او هذه المؤسسات نقص ما كانت
لتلقي بقوتها في ليبيا ما كانت لتلقي
بقوتها في في اليمن ما كانت لتغا امر به
الاستعداد لنقل قواتها الى حدود العراق
وغيرها من دول جوار اقليمي هذا ابتداء
ثانيا الحديث عن عدم وجود راضع قوي اعتقد
ان الاحكام الصادره بحق ما يعرف بعرب شركس
اليوم وتحويل كل القضايا المدنيه الى
القضايا العسكري واعتبار كل المؤسسات
المدنيه منشات عسكريه وبالتالي تحويل كل
من يقتر منها الى القضاء العسكري وافراط
القضاء العسكري في كل الاحكام اعتقد ان
هذا امر راض عمليات التشويه المستمر من
جانب وسائل الاعلام التابعه كليه للنظام
اعتقد ايضا انها وسيله من وسائل الرضع من
خلال تشويه الصوره الذهنيه للجميع هذا
ابتداء الحديث عن التطرف الفكري وان
الارهاب عرض لمرض وان اساسه هو التطرف
الفكري اعتقد ان ما تقوم به النخب
الليبراليه واليسار والنخب ايضا وبعض
النخب الاسلاميه لا استسن منهم احدا وبعض
النخب كل النخب السياسيه المحسوبه على
النظام السياسي تمارس تطرفا فكريا بالغ
السوء وصل الى حد تكفير الجميع تشويه صوره
الجميع تطوير مناهج التعليم و محاوله مسح
الهويه المجتمعيه للمجتمع المصري هذا
ابتداء الحديث عن الاستمرار اعتقد انه
كلما زادت عمليات القمع كلما كان هناك رد
فعل وبالتالي الحديث عن الافراط في
استخدام القوه الافراط في استخدام العنف
من جانب المؤسسات الامنيه والمؤسسات
والمؤسسات العسكريه هو في ذاته كفيل
باستمرار هذه العمليات في مواجهه هذه
المؤسسات هذا اولا ثانيا ان العمليات التي
استهدفت تهجير المواطنين العزل من اراضيهم
ومن مساكنهم ومن بيوتهم اعتقد انها في
ذاتها دافع لاستمرار معدلات الكراهيه
والحقد على هذه المؤسسات وبالتالي استمرار
هذه العمليات ايضا ثالثا وهو الاهم انه
لغير مستبعد على الاطلاق ان هناك صراعات
بين اجنحه وبين منظمات وان هناك عمليات
فساد فساد كبير داخل مؤسسات الاجهزه
الامنيه والمؤسسات العسكريه وبالتالي هناك
عمليات تنافس فيما بينها وهذا الفساد
الاداري والمالي احيانا والفساد العسكري
لدرجه امكانيه متاجرهم بالسلاح بين
القبائل المنتشره في شبه جزيره سناء
والطبيعه الجغرافيه هي احد العوامل ايضا
المهمه التي يجب التركيز عليها واثارتها
في استمرار الفشل في هذه الحملات سيد
توفيق ما ردك على كل هذه الملاحظات خاصه
وا ما جاء تحديدا بان الافراط في استعمال
القسوه ان صح التعبير وهذه الاحكام
القضائيه والتصديق على هذه الاحكام
الصادره عن القضاء العسكري بالاعدام الى
اي حد تعتبر عامل من عوامل تغذيه ربما هذا
المناخ المحتقن والمتوتر والذي ينعكس ربما
بالضروره على الاوضاع الامنيه
والعسكريه شوف حضرتك انا اعتقد ان
العمليات او كما نرى ان العمليات
الارهابيه تمت قبل ما تصدر الاحكام
القضائيه عليها بمعنى ان انا ما اقدرش
اقول ان العمليات الارهابيه دي بتحصل بسبب
الاحكام القضائيه ده هي حصلت اصلا قبل ما
يحصل ما يسميه الضيف الفاضل اسرا
معلش يعني نحن لم نربط يعني ازاي اه لا لا
لا لم نربط نربط عنوه بين هذا وك نتحدث عن
وضع عام عن مناخ عام عن عن عن مزاج عام
يعني في في المطلق
اه شوف المناخ العام طبعا الاحكام انت ما
بين خيارين يا اما تعطي احكام ضعيفه و وفي
هذه الحاله فما بيبقاش في راضع للارهابي
او المتطرف يا اما تضطر تدي احكام عنيفه
للغايه عشان ترضع ولكن ما يهم في الامر في
تصوري هو الا يظلم احد يعني دي اهم شيء في
الموضوع ولكن اذا كان هناك مجرم مثل اللي
حكم عليهم النهارده هم لم يحكم عليهم
لانهم وقفوا ضد ثوره يونيو هم حكم ما في
مليون واحد واقفوا ضد ثوره يونيو ولكن هم
حكم عليهم لانهم قاموا بافعال اجراميه
وعمليات قتل ودي مهمه جدا في التفرقه
ثانيا ضيفنا الفاضل بيشبه الليبراليين بان
هم لا يقل تطرفا لا لم نرى البراري واحد
يقوم بعمليه تفجيريه سيدي الفاضل يعني
احنا بنتكلم هنا عن شيئين مختلفين تماما
واحد له فكر مختلف عنك وبيعرض من حقه زي
ما من حقك تعرض فكرك ولكن المشكله هنا ان
الاخرين او الطوائف المتطرفه في جماعات
بعينها هم اللي بيستخدموا العنف انا لم
ارى البراري واحد الى الان يقوم بعمليه
انتحاريه في مصر اللي بيقوم بها تيار
الاسلام السياسي المتطرف وعلى راسه معروف
الجماعات اللي هي هي على مستوى العالم
بتتصل ببعضها وهم شيء واحد بس في النهايه
مجرد اسماء مختلفه فاعتقد انه من الظلم
يعني بصراحه ان احنا نقول ان ان في
متطرفين ليبراليين ويساو ايهم ضيفنا
الفاضل بالمتطرف اللي بيروح يفجر ويحرق
ويدمر اعتقد ده شيء مجافي للحقيقه تماما
طيب شكرا سنعود الى النقاش ولكن بعد فصل
قصير نتحدث بعدها عن نتائج اعتماد الحل
الامني للتعامل مع الاوضاع في مصر في ضوء
تطورات الخميس نرجو ان تبقوا
معنا اهلا بكم من جديد في هذه الحلقه التي
تناقش نجاعه مقاربات السلطه المصريه
للاوضاع في البلاد على ضوء احداث سناء
والتصديق على اعدام سبعه من [__]
الانقلاب الدكتور عبد الشافي ضيفنا من
واشنطن يقول بان هذه الاحكام احكام
الاعدام على قساوتها هي ايضا رساله رادعه
ما تعليقك لا عندما نتحدث عن احكام اعدام
يمكن ان تكون راضعه اذا كانت عادله ولكن
للاسف الشديد كل الاحكام او معظم حتى لا
اكون مبالغا معظم الاحكام التي صدرت عن
القضاء المصري وللاسف لا يستحق هذا اللقب
عن القضاء المصري منذ القلاب 3 يوليو وحتى
الان ليست عادله لانها لا تتفق وقواعد
القانونيه المنظمه سواء الداخليه او الدول
او الاقليميه التي صدقت عليها مصر
وتقنينها القواعد والمواثيق الدوليه معظم
الاحكام التي صدرت عن القضاء المصري منذ 3
يوليو وحتى الان يغلب عليها الطابع
السياسي في مرحله كبيره عندما كانت
الاحكام تصدر عن قضاء مدني كانت هذه
الاحكام مسيسه وفي مرحله لاحقه تم تهميش
القضاء المدني لتصبح السيطره للقضاء
العسكري وهذا ايضا منافي لما نص عليه
دستور الدستور او من يطلب ما يطلقون عليه
دستور 2014 هذا ابتداء الحديث عن ان
الافراط في الاحكام الرادعه يمكن ان يكون
وسيله للامن والاست تقرار هذا غير وارد
على الاطلاق لانه ابتداء غير عادل وغير
متفق مع القواعد الاساسيه بدليل ان هناك
عشرات ان لم يكن مئات الاحكام التي حصل
عليها نظوم رموز نظام مبارك بالبراءه في
مقابل رغم كل الجرائم التي تم ارتكابها في
مقابل هذه الاحكام التي يصفيها الدكتور
بالراضي مواجهه عدد من المتظاهرين ليس لهم
من الاساس هم سلميين وليس دعاه عنف او
دعاه تدمير سيد توفيق الرادع قد يكون كذلك
ولكن اذا ما كان عادلا يعني هذه القضيه
بتحديد يعني التصديق على هذه الاحكام
بالاعدام واجهتها الكثير من التحفظات حتى
من المحامين من الهيئات الحقوقيه واعطيك
مثال بسيط ان من بين المتهمين في هذه
القضيه من لم يكن موجودا اصلا يعني لحظه
وقوع الجريمه من قبل الامن كيف يمكن ان ان
تنعكس كل او ينعكس كل ذلك على الوضع سواء
كان في سناه او في غير سيناه
شوف حضرتك من حيث المثل اللي حضرتك اعطيته
انهه لم يكن متواجد وقت وقوع الجريمه فبن
لادن شخصيا ما كانش متواجد وقت ما
الطيارين اصطدموا في الابراج مش معناها ان
هو لو بن لادن وقع كان في ايد القوه
الدوليه ان هو ما يستحقش الاعدام لانه
اللي خطط واللي نظم واللي مول هو اكثر
اجراما من الارهابي اللي هو قد يكون مغيب
او مضلل ف يعني المثل لحضرتك اعطيته لا
يعني ما اعتقدش ان هو
يعني مثل يعني اقدر اعتمد عليه عشان اقول
ان ان ان انا ما احكم على هذا الشخص اما
الامر الاخر فهو انا لم اقل ان ان ان ان
فقط الاحكام
الرادعه هي الحل الاوحد او الامثل للقضيه
دي انا ذكرت بوضوح ان ان علاج القضيه دي
يبدا من قضيه فكريه سواء بالنسبه للشخص
الذي لم يت تطرف بعد انت محتاج له طرق
معينه في المفاهيم الدينيه تتصلح عاوز
مفاهيم فكريه معينه طريقه تفكير الانسان
ساعات حتى بره الدين تط احيانا اما اذا
وصل الى درجه ولكن نحن الان لا نرى اي
مقاربات فكريه فقط المقاربه الامنيه هي
سيده
الموقف
اه انا اتفق معاك ان هو الامر يحتاج الى
استراتيجيه فكريه تعليميه
واستخدام وسائل متعدده لمكافحه الظاهره دي
بصوره افضل من ذلك ولكن حتى لو تم ذلك
هتاخد بعض الوقت يعني ليه مادرش اقول
التغيير الفكري هيتم بين يوم وليله لكن
هنقدر نقول انه هيبقى سريع لان عندنا
وسائل تواصل اجتماعي وميديا النهارده بقت
سريعه فاعتقد عمليه التغيير الفكري الفكري
ممكن نعملها بصوره اسرع ولكن اتفق معك ان
هناك احتياج للمزيد من هذا الامر وان الحل
الامني
فقط ممكن يفيد ولكن لن يكون علاج نهائي
للقضيه دي لابد ان تعالج فكريا ا اولا
واخيرا هو ده حلها الرئيسي ولكن بيضطر
احيانا يعني انا قبل ان اعاتب على النظام
المصري انه اضطر يرد بالاحكام دي على
هؤلاء انا اعتقد اعاتب على الارهابيين
اللي بيروح يفجر
قطر ويحرقوا بيوت
ويقتلوا ضباط ويقتلوا عساكر ما لهمش اي ذم
واعتقد ان هو قبل ما اعاتب على رد الفعل
لابد ان اعاتب فاعله هو الذي اضطر النظام
ان هو يستخدم هذه الوسائل ولكن اتفق
نهائيا ان هناك ضروره حتميه للمواجهه
الفكريه لهذه القضيه بالاضافه للحلول
الامنيه اللي هي برده اعتقد انها ضروريه
لان ما تقدرش تواجه واحد مسلح مجرد بالفكر
مجرد وصل لمرحله التسليح انت تحتاج لقوه
لمواجهته فلا بد ان
الاثنين يعني يمشيان سواسيه او متوازيين
مع بعضهما البعض ولكن هل هل من المعقول
وضع المسلحين هذه الجماعات المسلحه
والمعارضين ك كقوه سياسيه في سله
واحده لا طبعا المسلح لابد ان يؤخذ بعين
الاعتبار بصوره مختلفه تماما المعارض
معارض اذا وقف الامر على المعارضه الفكريه
فاهلا به صدقني اما اذا رتب ودعم ومول
وشجع العمليات الارهابيه فالامر يختلف
تماما فهذا هو تحريض على الارهاب فلا بد
ان المعارض اذا كان صاحب فكر مختلف صدقني
اهلا به مهما كان فكره ولكن اذا دعم
الارهابيين باي صوره من الصور سواء صوره
فكريه او صوره ماديه او صوره لوجستيه فهذا
امر اخر ويوضع في هذه اللحظه في قائمه او
طائفه الارهابيين انفسهم السجون السجون
مليئه بالناشطين السياسيين
الان انا اعتقد ان هو اذا كان اي انسان
صاحب فكر فقط مختلف ولا يدعم بصوره او
باخرى الارهابيين او العمليات العنيفه
المسلحه فهذا الشخص اذا كان الامر معارضه
فكريه فقط لابد ان يحترم حقه كانسان في
معارضته الفكريه انا انا ارى ذلك الا اذا
كان بيدعم الانشطه اللي اللي اللي اللي
بتقوم بعمليات عنف ده موضوع ثاني يعني ده
دي قضيه اخرى طيب دكتور عبد الشافي اذا
كيف كيف الحكم على هذه المقاربه الامنيه
والاصرار على الاستمرار في استخدام هذه
المقاربه دون غيرها الحكم على هذه
المقاربه الامنيه ستقود الى مزيد من
التوتر مزيد من عدم الاستقرار مصر في اقل
من عامين من عامين منذ الانقلاب العسكري
الذي تحل ذكراه بعد شهرين من الان فقدت ما
يقرب من 100 الا شهيد مصر الان هناك اكثر
من 50 ال معتقل مصر الان هناك ما يقرب من
ربع مليون شاب مشردين خارج مصر وليس
داخلها بين المحافظات في ظل المطارده
الدكتور توفيق يتحدث عن المعارضين
الفكريين لهم مكان امن في ظل هذا النظام
لا اعتقد ان شيماء الصباغ عندما خرجت بيا
فطه وتم قتلها برصاص حي اعتقد او بخرطوش
من جانب الاجهزه الامنيه كانت معارضه تحمل
سلاحا اعتقد الدكتور توفيق لا عليه ان
يعيد مراجعه كثير من مقولاته وكثير من
افكاره لانها للاسف الشديد لا تتفق وال
الواقع القائم في مصر هناك انقلاب عسكري
يفرض في الاجرام يفرض في استخدام العنف
هذا الانقلاب العسكري لا يعنيه امن
واستقرار هذا الوطن هذا الانقلاب العسكري
كل ما يعنيه هو ضمان استمرار هيمنه وقمع
المؤسسه العسكريه على مقدرات الدوله
السياسيه والاقتصاديه والاجتماعيه
وثرواتها الطبيعيه وبالتالي لا مجال لا او
لا يفكر بالاساس في كل ما يهم هذا الوطن
او كيف ت مصير هذه المواجهه بالن مصير هذه
المواجهه اعتقد ان هناك استمرار في هذه
المواجهات طالما استمر هذا النظام في
سياسه وممارساته سواء باستخدامه الافراط
في استخدام القوه الافراط رات في الاحكام
القضائيه التي يمارسها الان المحكمه
العسكريه قبل الدخول على الهواء مباشره
كان هناك احكام باحاله 200 في محافظه و10
في محافظه وعشرات في محافظات اخرى لاحكام
للقضاء العسكري في مقابل مظاهرات سلميه
اعتقد ان استمرار الممارسات التي يقوم بها
الاجهزه الامنيه مثله في الداخليه
وسلطاتها وهيئتها الاجهزه العسكريه بما
تقوم به من حملات تنشيطيه في شبه جزيره
سيناء وضرب باستخدام بالطائرات وكذلك
الاحكام الرادعه التي يمارسها القضاء غير
العادل والمسيد في مصر سواء بجناحيه
المدني وال وكذلك عمليات التشويه المتعمد
التي تقوم بها الاجهزه الاعلاميه وكذلك
عمليه
التفريغ او طمس الهويه التي تقوم بها
المؤسسات الدينيه والتعليميه عند اسوا
القرارات الدكتور توفيق يتحدث عن مواجهه
فكريه اعتقد ان احد مظاهر المواجهه
الفكريه كانت حذف الدروس الخاصه بصلاح
الدين الايوبي وعقبه بن نافع من دروس طلبه
الثانويه العامه في مصر هذه هل هذه هي
المواجهه الفكريه التي حد تحدث عنها
الدكتور توفيق هناك حاجه الى اعاده نظر
كليه في سياسات هذا النظام في ممارساته في
كل الاساليب التي يعتمد عليها في مواجهت
لهذه الظواهر اعتقد بالاساس رقم واحد
الانقلاب العسكري هو المصدر الاول للعنف
في مصر وكل ما يتم ما هو الا رد فعل لهذه
الممارسات اشكرك دكتور عسام عبد الشافي
واشكر السيد توفيق حميد الباحث في شؤون
المصريه من واشنطن بهذا تنتهي هذه الحلقه
من برنامج مراء الخبر نلتقي باذن الله في
قراءه جديده في م وراء خبر جديد الى
اللقاء
ا